continuamos con ustedes en directo
América y es momento de hablar de las
noticias económicas con mi compañero
Juan Pablo luco y Juan Pablo Buen día
para usted Buenos días Ángela bueno y la
noticia con la que vamos a empezar es la
noticia económica del día también ha
estado en nuestros titulares y se trata
de los masivos despidos de Disney otra
de las grandes tecnológicas que toma una
dura decisión de hacer recortes así es y
no solo se trata de los recortes sino
también de todo el plan drástico de
reestructuración de la compañía que
veremos a continuación se trata de un
ahorro de
5.500 millones de en sus costos Esto es
lo que ellos planean también un plan de
recorte de 7.000 puestos de trabajo en
su plantilla laboral global para un
ahorro de mil millones de dólares este
ahorro ya está en marcha ellos ya han
empezado a hacer estos cambios y también
2500 millones en recortes no
relacionados con el contenido digamos
que estos recortes van más para temas de
pues estructura parques y demás Además
de eso
consumimos los cambios de la compañía
quedarían en tres grandes segmentos la
reorganización de su unidad de
entretenimiento que abarca cine
televisión y streaming una unidad espía
centrada en los deportes y una unidad de
reestructuración que diezmaría las
operaciones en parques experiencias y
productos de Disney todo con el objetivo
de hacer más eficiente la empresa más
grande de entretenimiento del mundo
veamos más información en el siguiente
informe
el reino de la magia está recortando
gastos en todo el mundo la compañía Walt
Disney emplea unas 220.000 personas pero
recientemente anunció que despedirá a
7.000 de ellas o el 3.6% de su fuerza
laboral como parte de un plan para
ahorrar 5500 millones de dólares la
empresa dijo que también está haciendo
otros recortes de costos operativos la
reestructuración se produce luego de que
Disney publicara sus ganancias del
primer trimestre del año el ingreso neto
de 1280 millones de dólares estuvo por
debajo de las expectativas de vuelta
como sí ou desde noviembre Bob aiger les
dijo a los analistas de Wall Street que
el enfoque de Disney es volverse más
rentable y eventualmente obtener
ganancias para su servicio de
transmisión de Disney Plus estamos
comprometidos a funcionar de manera
eficiente especialmente en un entorno
desafiante estábamos como empresa en una
carrera armamentista mundial para los
suscriptores
Disney Plus informó su primera
disminución en las suscripciones y
pérdidas de más de mil millones de
dólares un inversionista activista
también había estado presionando por
cambios y un asiento en la junta algo
que Disney está en contra en última
instancia el activismo gira alrededor de
Disney y creo que Iker y la junta son
muy conscientes de eso y es por eso que
necesitas hacer cosas como esta para ser
felices a todos porque las paredes
podrían comenzar a derrumbarse bastante
pronto
hay girl dijo que planea pedir que se
restablezcan los dividendos Este es el
tercer plan de reestructuración de
Disney en cinco años los recortes son la
forma en que aiger les dice a los
accionistas que está volviendo a
encarrilar al gigante de los medios
mucho ver el streaming pero no da Juan
Pablo vamos ahora hasta hacia el
principal fabricante de automóviles de
Japón no la está pasando bien a nivel
económico Ángela estamos hablando
precisamente de Toyota porque este
jueves la compañía reportó una caída del
8,1% en sus ganancias del tercer
trimestre fiscal debido a la escasez
mundial de chips para las computadoras
de los vehículos y también por el
aumento de Los costos de las materias
primas la compañía dijo que estaba
haciendo todo lo posible para encontrar
otros proveedores de chips para
satisfacer la demanda ya veremos Quiénes
serán los opcionados y también revisamos
las noticias económicas Juan Pablo de
América Latina Ángela arrancamos con El
Salvador porque recibió en 2022 un total
de 126,7 millones de dólares en remesas
mediante billeteras de criptomonedas lo
que representa el 1,63% del total de
estas Divisas también se conoció el dato
de inflación del país que por noveno mes
consecutivo se ubicó por encima del 7%
hasta
7,03 interanual en enero
la actividad de construcción de
Argentina tuvo un tibio crecimiento del
3,5% en 2022 un dato muy por debajo del
30,9% que acumuló en 2021 en sintonía
con una economía nacional que se enfrió
tras la fuerte recuperación que logró en
tras unos 18 días de haber estado
detenido el miércoles regresó el
servicio de trenes en el área del
complejo turístico de Machu Picchu en
Perú fueron casi tres semanas sin
servicio en esta zona turística del país
esto a causa de los bloqueos de las vías
férreas por las protestas antiburales
que han sacudido el país
y Juan Pablo para su cierre la cifra del
día que otra vez nos lleva a Turquía y a
Siria Así es cuatro mil millones de
dólares en pérdidas económicas por el
devastador terremoto entre Siria y
Turquía una cifra proporcionada por la
agencia de calificación Fish pero que
nunca se va a comparar con los 17.500
fallecidos que ha dejado hasta ahora la
catástrofe Lamentablemente Así es Juan
Pablo y además seguimos actualizando
cifras cada hora Gracias a usted ahora
volvemos con más